From headline-grabbing Ponzi schemes to email fishing identity thieves to fake news stories circulating on social media, it can sometimes seem like the world is full of people who want to deceive us. What many of these scammers and con artists have in common is that they take advantage of the patterns of thinking and the mental shortcuts that we all use in our daily lives. Most of the time, these mental habits serve us well. After all, most people aren't trying to trick us, and it would be different. to go through life skeptical of everything and everyone. But the same habits of trust and belief that work well most of the time can leave us vulnerable when we encounter a con artist, a false news story, or some other type of deceit. So what are the cognitive habits that put us at risk of believing lies and falling prey to scams? Are some people simply more gullible than others or can anyone be conned?
从抢占头条的庞氏骗局，到网络钓鱼的身份窃贼，再到在社交媒体上流传的虚假新闻，有时世界似乎充满了想要欺骗我们的人。这些骗子和诈骗犯的共同点在于，他们利用了我们日常生活中所使用的思维模式和心理捷径。大多数时候，这些心理习惯对我们很有帮助。毕竟，大多数人并不是想欺骗我们，如果对生活中的一切和每个人都持怀疑态度，那将是另一种生活方式。但这些在大多数情况下行之有效的信任和信念习惯，当我们遇到骗子、虚假新闻或其他类型的欺骗时，却可能让我们变得脆弱。那么，究竟是哪些认知习惯让我们面临相信谎言和沦为骗局受害者的风险呢？有些人是否天生就比其他人更容易受骗，还是说任何人都有可能被骗？
when you're offered something that sounds like an amazing opportunity, what questions should you ask to figure out if it's too good to be true? How common is fraud in the worlds of business, science, and elsewhere? Is technology, including artificial intelligence, making it easier for people to cheat and lie and to get away with it? And what can we do to protect ourselves and our wallets by spotting scammers before it's too late? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
当你被提供一个听起来像是绝佳机会的东西时，你应该问什么问题来判断它是否好得令人难以置信？欺诈在商业、科学和其他领域有多普遍？包括人工智能在内的技术是否让人们更容易欺骗和撒谎，并逃脱惩罚？我们能做些什么来通过在为时已晚之前识别骗子来保护我们自己和我们的钱包？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. I have two guests today, co-authors of the new book Nobody's Fool, Why We Get Taken in and What We Can Do About It. First is Dr. Daniel Simons, a professor of psychology and head of the visual cognition laboratory at the University of Illinois Urbana-Champaign, where he also has a doctor. He has a doctor of courtesy appointments in the Department of Advertising and the College of Business. Dr. Simon's research explores the limits of human awareness and memory, the reasons we're often unaware of those limits, and the implications of those limits for our personal and professional lives. Next is Dr. Christopher Chabree, a professor and co-director of the Behavioral Decision Sciences
该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我有两位嘉宾，他们是新书《没人是傻瓜：为什么我们会被骗以及我们能做些什么》的合著者。第一位是丹尼尔·西蒙斯博士，他是心理学教授，也是伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校视觉认知实验室的负责人，他在广告系和商学院也担任客座教授。西蒙斯博士的研究探索了人类意识和记忆的局限性，我们往往没有意识到这些局限性的原因，以及这些局限性对我们个人和职业生活的影响。接下来是克里斯托弗·查布里斯博士，他是行为决策科学教授兼联合主任
program at the Geisinger Health System. Dr. Chabry is a cognitive scientist whose research focuses on decision-making, attention, intelligence, and behavior genetics. Dr. Simons and Dr. Chebrey were also co-authors of the 2010 New York Times bestseller, The Invisible Gorilla, How Our Intuitions Deceive Us. They've collaborated on research for more than 25 years and spent nearly a decade working on their new book, which explores how scammers, con, artists, and other liars fool us, and what we can do to avoid being taken in. Thank you both for joining me today. Thanks for having us on. Great to be here.
盖辛格卫生系统项目的联合主任。查布里斯博士是一位认知科学家，他的研究重点是决策、注意力、智力和行为遗传学。西蒙斯博士和查布里斯博士也是2010年《纽约时报》畅销书《看不见的大猩猩：我们的直觉如何欺骗我们》的合著者。他们合作研究超过25年，并花了近十年时间撰写这本新书，书中探讨了骗子、诈骗犯和其他撒谎者如何愚弄我们，以及我们能做些什么来避免上当受骗。感谢两位今天加入我的节目。谢谢邀请我们。很高兴来到这里。
You start your book with a quote from James Mattis, the former U.S. Defense Secretary, who said, once in a while we can all be fooled by something. He was talking about the fact that he served on the board of the disgraced company, Theranos, before it was revealed as a fraud. So let's start there. Why is it that we're all vulnerable to being deceived, at least some of the time? I think we tend to think that only the most gullible among us can be deceived, and there's good reason for that.
你们的书以美国前国防部长詹姆斯·马蒂斯的一句话开头，他说：“偶尔我们所有人都会被某事愚弄。”他谈到的是他曾在声名狼藉的Theranos公司董事会任职，后来该公司被揭露为一场骗局。那么我们就从这里开始吧。为什么我们所有人至少在某些时候容易受到欺骗？我认为我们倾向于认为只有我们中最容易受骗的人才会被欺骗，这不无道理。
Whenever you hear about a scam or you hear about somebody falling for a con, in retrospect, it seems obvious. And you can think to yourself, oh, yeah, I wouldn't have fallen for that. But most scams aren't targeting you, right? They're targeting somebody. And when a scam is really targeted to you in particular that meets your desires, your wishes, your wants, you're more likely to fall for it than if it's not.
每当你听说一个骗局或听说有人上当受骗时，事后看来，这似乎显而易见。你会对自己说，哦，是的，我才不会上当呢。但大多数骗局并不是针对你的，对吧？它们是针对某人的。当一个骗局特别针对你，满足了你的欲望、愿望和需求时，你比它不针对你时更容易上当。
So we all can be subject to being deceived. if the targeting is aimed at us and it takes advantage of the way we think and the way and the information we're looking for. So, Dr. Chivri, let me ask you, what are some of the most common cognitive shortcuts or thinking patterns that get us into trouble? I think the first one that we talk about is truth bias. So truth bias is the idea that our default tendency is to think that whatever we hear or read or encounter is true. that people are not always trying to lie to us or deceive us. And that's sort of a precondition for being taken in by any kind of scam or con or fraud.
所以，如果目标针对我们，并且利用了我们的思维方式和我们正在寻找的信息，我们所有人都有可能被欺骗。那么，查布里斯博士，请问，有哪些最常见的认知捷径或思维模式会让我们陷入困境？我认为我们谈到的第一个是“真相偏见”。真相偏见是指我们的默认倾向是认为我们听到、读到或遇到的任何事情都是真实的。人们并不总是试图对我们撒谎或欺骗我们。这是被任何形式的骗局、诈骗或欺诈所欺骗的前提条件。
Because if you believed everything you saw was false or questionable or misleading, then you wouldn't really act on those offers and those promises and those sales pitches and those marketing messages. And truth bias is important for us to have because if we didn't tend to accept other people said we'd never be able to make plans with them, have a conversation with them, or do anything really other than be skeptical all the time. Once you start with truth bias, then other cognitive habits we have can get us into further trouble.
因为如果你认为你所看到的一切都是虚假的、可疑的或误导性的，那么你就不会真正去采取行动回应那些提议、承诺、推销和营销信息。真相偏见对我们很重要，因为如果我们不倾向于接受别人所说的话，我们就永远无法与他们制定计划、进行对话，或者除了时刻保持怀疑之外什么也做不了。一旦你从真相偏见开始，我们拥有的其他认知习惯就会让我们陷入更深的麻烦。
And I guess one I would highlight to start with is our habit of focus, which refers to our tendency to focus on information that's right in front of us that we have easily at hand, often that someone has provided to us, and make decisions based only on that information, operating essentially under the assumption that that's all that matters or that's all there is. And one of the main ways to avoid being deceived is to think about information that people aren't showing you, or information that's missing or has been withhold or you're just not thinking about,
我想首先强调的一个习惯是我们的“关注习惯”，它指的是我们倾向于关注眼前容易获得的信息，这些信息通常是别人提供给我们的，并仅根据这些信息做出决定，本质上假设这就是全部重要内容或全部信息。避免被欺骗的主要方法之一是思考别人没有向你展示的信息，或者缺失的、被隐瞒的，或者你只是没有想到的信息，
broadening your focus to include other information besides perhaps what the scam or a con artist wants you to be focusing on at that particular moment. So it's especially easy to fool people when you tell them something that they want to believe. anyway, or something that matches the preconceived notion. So how can we fall into the trap of not being willing to re-examine our own beliefs? This is a general issue, right, that we tend to make predictions about the world. We have to, right? We have to have expectations for what's going to happen, and we can act on those. And most of the time, that's a great thing to do. And that's true for most of these sort of cognitive tendencies. They generally work really well for us. It's only when somebody is hijacking them to take advantage of us that we run into problems. So the problem with
拓宽你的关注范围，将除了骗子或诈骗犯在特定时刻想让你关注的信息之外的其他信息也纳入考虑。所以，当你告诉人们他们本来就想相信的事情，或者符合他们先入为主观念的事情时，欺骗他们就特别容易。那么，我们如何才能陷入不愿重新审视自己信念的陷阱呢？这是一个普遍的问题，对吧？我们倾向于对世界做出预测。我们必须这样做，对吧？我们必须对将要发生的事情有预期，并据此采取行动。大多数时候，这很好。对于大多数这类认知倾向来说也是如此。它们通常对我们非常有效。只有当有人劫持它们来利用我们时，我们才会遇到问题。所以，关于
predictions and expectations is that when somebody gives us exactly what we're looking for, we don't tend to question it as much as we would if somebody told us the opposite of what we believe. So you're much more likely to forward that story on Facebook or Instagram or wherever if it matches your beliefs without stopping to think, hey, is that really true or might it be false. Even in research, we tend to be much more willing to question our findings if it looks like they came out the opposite of what we were expecting, than if they came out exactly as we predicted. And that tendency to just not double-check ourselves can get us into trouble. Well, you just mentioned the world of science, and I know in your book you've given
预测和期望的问题在于，当有人给我们提供我们想要的东西时，我们往往不会像别人告诉我们与我们信念相反的事情那样去质疑它。所以，如果它符合你的信念，你更有可能在Facebook、Instagram或其他任何地方转发那个故事，而不会停下来思考：嘿，那是真的吗，还是可能是假的？即使在研究中，如果我们的发现看起来与我们预期的相反，我们往往比它们完全符合我们的预测时更愿意质疑我们的发现。而这种不进行复核的倾向可能会让我们陷入困境。嗯，你刚才提到了科学界，我知道在你们书中你们给出了
several examples of scientists, including psychologists, unfortunately, who have gotten away with fraud and deception in some cases for many years. How common is scientific fraud and how should non-scientists think about this when they're trying to read and make sense of the science news that they may be reading in publications that they look at all the time? I don't know if we have a good estimate of what the base rate of scientific fraud is because it hasn't all been uncovered. So we can't go back to, you know, the last 100,000 publications and count up how many were fraudulent or had other kinds of fabrications or anything like that. So it's probably more common than the detected cases so far would have you believe,
几个科学家的例子，不幸的是，其中也包括心理学家，他们在某些情况下多年来一直逃脱了欺诈和欺骗。科学欺诈有多普遍？当非科学家试图阅读和理解他们经常在出版物中看到的科学新闻时，他们应该如何看待这个问题？我不知道我们是否对科学欺诈的基准率有一个很好的估计，因为它并没有全部被揭露出来。所以我们无法回到过去，比如查看过去10万份出版物，统计有多少是欺诈性的或有其他类型的捏造等等。所以它可能比迄今为止检测到的案例所显示的要普遍得多，
but it's probably not as common as some of the biggest critics of scientific fields would want you to believe either. Most scientists that I know, and I'm sure that Dan knows and most scientists in the world, are trying to get accurate results. They're trying to report what they actually did. They're not deliberately falsifying things. But in a climate where it's reasonable to expect that scientific results that are reported are honest and true and not false, a few people can get away with inserting themselves into the process and deliberately. creating things that will then slip through and, you know, get fabricated results into the literature. I think that the general public should be skeptical of specific scientific results if they detect signs like, well, this is based on a very small sample size. It's based on a, you know,
但它可能也没有科学界的一些最大批评者想要你相信的那么普遍。我认识的大多数科学家，我相信丹也认识，世界上大多数科学家都在努力获得准确的结果。他们试图报告他们实际所做的事情。他们不是故意伪造东西。但在一个合理的预期是所报告的科学结果是诚实、真实而非虚假的气候下，少数人可以设法介入这个过程，并故意制造一些东西，然后溜过去，将捏造的结果带入文献中。我认为公众如果发现了一些迹象，比如“这是基于非常小的样本量”，就应该对特定的科学结果持怀疑态度。它基于一个，你知道，
a single study. It hasn't replicated by independent researchers. It's getting hyped quite a lot in the media and yet nobody else seems to be able to reproduce these findings. It has a gigantic impact from a very tiny intervention. That's a sign that something might be overblown or misleading or perhaps even made up. But when you encounter sort of the general considered opinions of large bodies of scientists who've really looked carefully at work and done, you know, dozens, hundreds, thousands of studies over years, those are those are the kinds of things that people should really, should really trust and rely on. Just add to that, that we tend to have this impression that discoveries happen in a bolt of insight
单一的研究。它没有被独立研究人员复制。它在媒体上被大肆炒作，但似乎没有人能够重现这些发现。它通过一个微小的干预产生了巨大的影响。这是一个迹象，表明某些东西可能被夸大了、具有误导性，甚至可能是编造的。但是，当你遇到大量科学家对真正仔细审视过的工作所持的普遍共识，并且他们多年来进行了数十、数百、数千项研究时，这些才是人们真正应该信任和依赖的东西。补充一点，我们往往有这种印象，即发现发生在灵光一现中，
in a single finding. And that's not how discovery in science works, right? If we want to make a claim that something is a truth about people in psychology, that's often what we want to do. We want to say this is a truth about people, their behaviors, their beliefs, their traits, you're not going to typically come to a definitive conclusion about all people from one study, especially very small studies. Discovery involves sort of incremental understanding of an idea and testing it in a wide range of contexts to make sure it actually applies more broadly.
在一个单一的发现中。科学发现并不是这样运作的，对吧？如果我们想声称某事是关于心理学中人的真理，这通常是我们想做的。我们想说这是关于人、他们的行为、信念、特质的真理，你通常不会从一项研究中得出关于所有人的结论，尤其是非常小的研究。发现涉及对一个想法的渐进式理解，并在广泛的背景下进行测试，以确保它确实更广泛地适用。
It might be a discovery about one tiny little sample at one time, maybe, but if it doesn't, if you don't test whether it's general to a lot of contexts and to a lot of people, it's not really a broad discovery. in the sense that we tend to think of in science. So I would be wary of single studies. This is a new study that's told us something that we didn't know before and that nobody ever thought of before. That tends to be something that's getting overhyped. Now, a lot of scams involve promising something that's too good to be true,
它可能是一个关于某一次某一个小样本的发现，也许是这样，但如果你不测试它是否适用于许多背景和许多人，它在科学中我们倾向于认为的意义上并不是一个广泛的发现。所以我对单一研究会持谨慎态度。这是一项告诉我们以前不知道且以前没人想到的事情的新研究。这往往是那些被过度炒作的东西。现在，许多骗局涉及承诺一些好得令人难以置信的事情，
like an investment opportunity that offers unheard of returns or a company that promises a miracle medical cure. if you're offered something that sounds like an amazing opportunity, what are the questions to ask yourself to decide if it falls into that too good to be true category? I can start with that. We all know that when something is too good to be true, we shouldn't believe it. That's something that everybody kind of knows that if it seems too good to be true, it probably is. The problem is what sounds too good to be true to one person is just good enough for another person. So for somebody else, they're going to find that as just plausible enough that they're going to jump in.
比如提供闻所未闻回报的投资机会，或者承诺奇迹般医疗治愈的公司。如果你被提供一个听起来像是绝佳机会的东西，你应该问自己什么问题来决定它是否属于“好得令人难以置信”的类别？我可以从这里开始。我们都知道，当某事好得令人难以置信时，我们不应该相信它。这是每个人都知道的事情，如果它看起来好得令人难以置信，它可能就是。问题在于，对一个人来说听起来好得令人难以置信的事情，对另一个人来说却刚刚好。所以对其他人来说，他们会觉得这足够合理，以至于他们会跳进去。
The challenge in deciding when something's too good to be true is in making sure that you view it kind of skeptically from the beginning. So if something seems really promising, really amazing, you should take a step back and say, what would I need to know in order to verify that that's actually true? We know that if somebody offers you 50% returns on your investment with a guaranteed, of no losses all within a year. Almost certainly not true because no investment does that. So you can take a step back and say, what would they have to be doing to be able to make that claim?
决定某事何时好得令人难以置信的挑战在于确保你从一开始就以怀疑的眼光看待它。所以，如果某事看起来非常有希望、非常惊人，你应该退后一步，问自己：我需要知道什么才能验证它确实是真的？我们知道，如果有人向你提供50%的投资回报，并保证一年内没有损失。这几乎肯定不是真的，因为没有任何投资能做到这一点。所以你可以退后一步，问：他们必须做什么才能做出这种声明？
And as soon as you start questioning it a little bit, you might realize that now this really actually is too good to be true. I was just going to say, what about the case of Bernie Madoff where it was too good to be true and yet he was paying people? So you didn't really have a reason to question other than, well, the market isn't behaving this well, and yet I'm still getting 15% returns every year. I mean, how do you escape being in a situation like that? So too good to be true, as Dan said, can mean different things to different people, but there are some signs that are pretty common for things that are too good to be true,
一旦你开始稍微质疑它，你可能会意识到，不，这实际上确实好得令人难以置信。我正想说，伯尼·麦道夫的案例怎么样？那件事好得令人难以置信，但他确实在付钱给人们。所以你并没有真正的理由去质疑，除了“嗯，市场表现得没那么好，但我每年仍然能获得15%的回报”。我的意思是，你怎么能避免陷入那种情况？所以，正如丹所说，好得令人难以置信对不同的人可能意味着不同的事情，但对于那些好得令人难以置信的事情，确实有一些非常常见的迹象，
or at least that shouldn't be believed. And in the case of Bernie Madoff, what he was offering wasn't really necessarily too good. It was not a really huge rate of return. It was 8 to 12% a year, which is a little bit above the long run average of the stock market, but not, you know, not too much. It's nothing like what an original Ponzi scheme was offering or what a lot of cryptocurrency offers the, you know, recently have offered. But the telltale sign was that it was every single year. There was never a losing year. There was barely ever even a losing month. He managed to make the returns on his investors' investments, you know, fit within that narrow band. So the excessive consistency there was, I think, what trapped people. They thought, this is a sure thing.
或者至少是不应该相信的事情。在伯尼·麦道夫的案例中，他提供的并不一定真的太好。那不是一个非常高的回报率。每年8%到12%，这比股票市场的长期平均水平高出一点点，但并没有，你知道，高出太多。这与最初的庞氏骗局所提供的，或者最近许多加密货币所提供的完全不同。但明显的迹象是，它是每年都这样。从来没有亏损的一年。甚至几乎从来没有亏损的一个月。他设法使投资者的投资回报，你知道，保持在那个狭窄的范围内。所以那里的过度一致性，我认为就是困住人们的原因。他们认为，这绝对是稳赚不赔的。
I will never lose. I'll get the same amount per year. Kind of like a treasury bill or some kind of bond or savings account, but just with a much higher rate of return. And that was, I think, the innovation. Like, really the true novelty of Madoffs, it's called a Ponzi scheme, but some people call it a Madoff scheme because he really added this new dimension of not offering people the ridiculous proposition. that educated people, maybe who've been in the stock market for a while, know is unrealistic, the 50% in six months or a year or something like that. But offering something that seems much more reasonable, it wasn't too good to be true in the sense of the total amount of money they
我永远不会输。我每年都会得到同样的金额。有点像国库券、某种债券或储蓄账户，只是回报率高得多。我认为这就是创新之处。麦道夫骗局真正的创新之处在于，虽然它被称为庞氏骗局，但有些人称之为麦道夫骗局，因为他确实增加了一个新的维度，即不再向人们提供那种荒谬的提议。受过教育的人，也许在股市里待过一段时间的人，都知道这是不现实的，比如六个月或一年内获得50%的回报之类的。但他提供了一些看起来合理得多的东西，从他们赚取的总金额来看，这并不是好得令人难以置信。
made. It was too good to be true in the sense of the consistency with which they made it. So consistency or the lack of it is an important sort of sign of fraud that people can, you know, pay more attention to than they might otherwise. That happens in science too, right? So one of the hallmarks of fraud in clinical trials is if the baseline conditions, when people are measured at the beginning, you'll often do checks to make sure that the people assigned to the treatment and the placebo group were the same in other ways so that those aren't sort of contaminating the effects of your treatment. So you kind of expect the two groups to be balanced on prior health conditions, for example, or age. And if they're all perfectly balanced, that's weird. That's a red flag because just by chance, if you randomly assign people to groups, they won't all end up perfectly balanced. You'll end up with a distribution, with some differing on some factors and not on others. And it's turned out that that's been a major way of finding fraud in a number of disciplines from anesthesiology to any field that has clinical medical trials.
好得令人难以置信的是他们赚取这些钱的一致性。因此，一致性或缺乏一致性是欺诈的一个重要迹象，人们可以比平时更加注意这一点。这种情况在科学界也存在，对吧？临床试验中欺诈的一个标志是基线条件，当人们在开始时进行测量时，你通常会进行检查，以确保分配到治疗组和安慰剂组的人在其他方面是相同的，这样就不会干扰你治疗的效果。所以你通常会期望两组在之前的健康状况或年龄等方面是平衡的。如果它们完全平衡，那就很奇怪了。这是一个危险信号，因为如果你随机分配人员到组中，他们不可能最终完全平衡。你会得到一个分布，在某些因素上有所不同，而在其他因素上则不然。事实证明，这是从麻醉学到任何有临床医学试验的领域中发现欺诈的主要方式。
So your book warrants people to be wary of the butterfly effect. What do you mean by that? Well, so the old anecdote goes that a butterfly flapping its wings in Brazil can cause a tornado in Texas. And that's based on sort of old, well, not old, but relatively new ideas about chaos theory and, you know, certain attempts to model how, you know, small changes in one place can perturb a system so that some dramatic thing happens someplace else. people tend to be too accepting of the idea that tiny little interventions in the world, not random things like butterflies flapping their wings, but maybe very small, very small, very brief interventions. For example, giving like a half hour or an hour long sort of like reflective exercise at the beginning of college can cause big changes in people's GPA and, you know, willingness to,
所以你的书提醒人们要警惕蝴蝶效应。你是什么意思？嗯，古老的轶事说，在巴西拍动翅膀的蝴蝶可能会在德克萨斯州引起龙卷风。这基于关于混沌理论的旧观念，或者说相对较新的观念，以及某些试图模拟小变化如何在某处扰动系统从而导致其他地方发生戏剧性事件的尝试。人们往往太容易接受这种观点，即世界上微小的干预——不是像蝴蝶拍动翅膀那样的随机事件，而是非常微小、非常短暂的干预——可能会产生巨大影响。例如，在大学开始时进行半小时或一小时的反思练习，可能会导致人们的平均绩点（GPA）以及留在大学并完成学位的意愿发生巨大变化，等等，这只是这类效应的一个例子。
stay in college and complete the degree and so on, just to give one example of this class of, of this class of effects. Another one is priming studies, the idea that sort of very brief exposures to stimuli we don't notice or remember encountering can dramatically change our behaviors or beliefs, you know, just a few seconds, minutes, or even longer later. There's one particular dramatic example where a study claimed that subliminally seeing the, you know, Israeli flag caused people to be more likely to vote and vote for centrist parties as opposed to as opposed to more extreme parties, you know, days, weeks later in an actual election. And that's just the kind of thing that you should look up and say, how plausible is it that
另一个例子是启动效应研究，即我们没有注意到或记得遇到的刺激的非常短暂的接触，可能会在几秒钟、几分钟甚至更久之后戏剧性地改变我们的行为或信念。有一个特别戏剧性的例子，一项研究声称，潜意识地看到以色列国旗会导致人们在几天、几周后的实际选举中更有可能投票，并投票给中间派政党，而不是更极端的政党。这正是你应该去查证并思考的事情：某件发生在你身上仅150毫秒的事情，在十月份发生，却改变了你在十一月份投票站的行为，这有多大的可信度？
something that happened to you for 150 milliseconds, you know, in October, changed, you know, what you did in the voting booth in November. And there are many, many studies and stories like this, which we sort of take to mean that there's an inherent appeal to the idea that we could discover these little tiny things that made a vast difference. And if we did discover them, that would be great, right? It's not irrational to say we should want tiny, cheap things that make, you know, huge outcomes. A vaccine is one of those things, right? It's a tiny little injection that you get once that might prevent you from getting a disease for the rest of your life in some cases. It's just that those are rare, those are rare events in science.
有很多很多这样的研究和故事，我们认为这表明人们有一种内在的吸引力，认为我们可以发现这些产生巨大差异的小事。如果我们真的发现了它们，那不是很好吗？说我们应该想要那些能产生巨大成果的微小、廉价的东西，这并不非理性。疫苗就是其中之一，对吧？它是一次性的小注射，在某些情况下可以防止你终身患病。只是在科学中，这些是罕见的事件。
They're not the things that are coming out every day in our psychology journals, unfortunately. And that's a sort of general principle, that any time you see a big effect from a small intervention, that's when you should require the strongest evidence. You shouldn't go to the bank on a single study showing something like that because the odds are good in those sorts of cases that it's not going to replicate in the same way that we think we are. Or it's not going to be general in the way that it was claimed. Those are going to be the effects that are sort of really engaging and exciting and more likely to be wrong because it's really rare to have giant, effect sizes from tiny little variation, tiny little interventions. So do either of you have a favorite con or scam you came across in researching the book?
不幸的是，它们并不是每天出现在我们心理学期刊上的东西。这是一个普遍原则：任何时候当你看到微小的干预产生巨大的效果时，那正是你应该要求最强有力证据的时候。你不应该把赌注押在显示这种结果的单一研究上，因为在这些情况下，它很可能不会像我们认为的那样重复出现。或者它不会像声称的那样具有普遍性。那些往往是真正引人入胜、令人兴奋且更容易出错的效果，因为从微小的变化或微小的干预中获得巨大的效应量是非常罕见的。那么，你们在研究这本书时，有没有遇到过最喜欢的骗局？
And I'm using the word favorite in air quotes here. And why is it your favorite and what can we learn from it? I'll start with one that I knew about before we started writing the book, but I learned a lot more about it in researching the book. And that's the famous case. of John von Neumann. You may have heard of John von Neumann as a famous economist, mathematician, computer scientist, game theorist, one of really the fathers of sort of modern science. But it was also the name taken by a guy who entered a chess tournament in 1993 under that name. I don't think it was his real name, but he entered a chess tournament under that name. In 1993, this was 30 years ago, actually 30 years ago this month, in fact, July 1993. And notice, no one.
我在这里给“最喜欢”加上了引号。为什么它是你最喜欢的，我们能从中吸取什么教训？我先从一个我在写书之前就知道的案例开始，但在研究过程中我了解得更多。那就是约翰·冯·诺依曼的著名案例。你可能听说过约翰·冯·诺依曼，他是一位著名的经济学家、数学家、计算机科学家、博弈论专家，真的是现代科学之父之一。但这也是一个在1993年以这个名字参加国际象棋比赛的人所使用的名字。我不认为那是他的真名，但他确实以那个名字参加了比赛。那是1993年，也就是30年前，事实上就在这个月的30年前，1993年7月。请注意，没有人。
Nobody had ever heard of the guy before. He didn't even play chess. He didn't even touch the pieces and move the pieces as though he had ever played in the chess tournament before. He looked like a complete outsider and novice. And yet he drew with a grandmaster and beat masters and was doing really well in this chess tournament. And in fact, tied for a prize at the end. He didn't win every game. Some games he would just sort of like suddenly like stop playing for no reason for 40 minutes and just let his time run out.
以前从来没有人听说过这个人。他甚至不会下棋。他甚至不像以前参加过国际象棋比赛那样去触摸棋子和移动棋子。他看起来完全是个外行和新手。然而，他与一位特级大师打平，击败了大师，并且在这次比赛中表现得非常好。事实上，最后还并列获得了奖项。他并没有赢得每一场比赛。有些比赛他会突然无缘无故地停止下棋40分钟，任由时间耗尽。
or some games he would try to make illegal moves and just sort of stop. At the end of the tournament, though, he had won enough games to win a prize, but everybody was suspicious about how this guy could be doing it. And so they didn't really know exactly how, but they thought he couldn't, like this, this can't happen. So the tournament director, a guy named Bill Goichberg, who I've actually known since the very first chess tournament I played in, didn't want to give money to this guy who he thought might be cheating somehow, but you didn't know whether he was cheating or how he was cheating.
或者有些比赛他会试图走违规的棋，然后就停下来。不过在比赛结束时，他赢得了足够的比赛来获得奖项，但每个人都怀疑这家伙是怎么做到的。所以他们并不确切知道他是怎么做到的，但他们认为他不可能做到，这不可能发生。所以比赛主管，一个叫比尔·戈伊奇伯格的人，我从我参加的第一场国际象棋比赛起就认识他了，他不想给这个他认为可能以某种方式作弊的家伙发奖金，但他不知道他是否在作弊，或者他是如何作弊的。
So he set up on the chess board, before writing him a check, he set up on the chess board a very simple chess puzzle that a five-year-old who had learned the game a month earlier could probably have solved. And he refused to even try it and he walked out and essentially was never seen before. And so the reason why I love that con so much, and it's generally agreed now that basically what the guy was doing was probably concealing an earpiece and getting information transmitted to him by an accomplice who was using a computer to help fix. figure out what moves to play and was sort of sending code to him, like through an earpiece saying, you know, move this piece from here to there. But if the transmission broke down, he would just stop and wait to hear something, you know, and so that didn't help him solve the puzzle at the end, you know. So what the lesson that we drew from this for, for what you can do yourself is, you know, it would be tempting to just write the check and move on, you know, and our habit of efficiency sort of
所以，在给他写支票之前，他在棋盘上摆了一个非常简单的国际象棋残局，一个一个月前刚学会下棋的五岁小孩可能都能解开。但他甚至拒绝尝试，直接走了出去，基本上再也没有出现过。所以我之所以如此喜欢这个骗局，是因为现在普遍认为，这家伙基本上是在隐藏一个耳机，并由一个同伙通过电脑帮助他确定走哪步棋，然后通过耳机向他发送代码，告诉他把这枚棋子从这里移到那里。但如果传输中断，他就会停下来等待听到什么，所以这对他解决最后的残局没有帮助。那么我们从中得出的教训是，你可以自己做些什么：直接写支票然后继续前进是很诱人的，我们追求效率的习惯导致我们只是匆忙做出决定。
leads us to sort of just, you know, move on with things like make quick decisions and so on. But Goichberg thought to ask one more question of this guy and do a little tiny test and see whether he really was what he purported to be that as a chess master. And in, you know, in 10 seconds, he had his answer, right, when the guy refused to do it and started arguing and left. So we advise anybody to really think about what questions you could ask. Sometimes it only takes just one to get a crucial additional piece of information that will let you decide whether you're being conned or scammed or whether something is legitimate. And that's just my favorite example because of the whole story that surrounds it. Yeah. I could talk about one that I think is more
但戈伊奇伯格想到要再问这个家伙一个问题，做一个小小的测试，看看他是否真的是他所声称的那种国际象棋大师。在10秒钟内，他得到了答案，当那个人拒绝做这个测试并开始争论然后离开时。所以我们建议任何人都要真正思考你可以问什么问题。有时只需要一个问题就能获得关键的额外信息，让你决定自己是否被骗了，或者某件事是否合法。这就是我最喜欢的例子，因为围绕它的整个故事。是的。我可以谈谈一个我认为你或我更有可能遇到的骗局。
likely to be encountered by you or me, right, which is what's known as a call center scam. And these are scams that we all have encountered. So if you've gotten calls asking you to call back to extend your car's warranty, right? The best thing. majority of those are scams, because most of us don't need to do that. And you've probably never called back that number. But anybody who does has selected themselves as somebody who is likely, or more likely at least, to send money. It's the same way that the famous Nigerian email scam works, that it looks ridiculous on its face to most people. But it doesn't have to convince most people. It only has to convince the people who find it really appealing and who are most
也就是所谓的呼叫中心诈骗。这些是我们都遇到过的骗局。如果你接到电话要求你回电以延长汽车保修期，对吧？其中绝大多数都是骗局，因为我们大多数人不需要这样做。你可能从来没有回拨过那个号码。但任何回拨的人都已经把自己筛选为更有可能汇款的人。这和著名的尼日利亚电子邮件诈骗的工作原理是一样的，对大多数人来说，它表面上看起来很荒谬。但它不需要说服大多数人。它只需要说服那些觉得它非常有吸引力并且最有可能上当的人。
likely to fall for that particular pitch. So you can send out millions of emails and only reach a tiny number of people who are going to send back there and respond, but that's exactly what you want, right? You only want to interact with the people who are most likely to give you their bank account number. But call center scams have taken on a new form, which is to put people under huge time pressure and threaten them. So, for example, saying, you owe money to the IRS, and unless you pay it right now, the police will come knock down your door. Right. And what they all, they all often we'll ask people to do is go out and buy a prepaid cash card and then read the number over the phone. Most people aren't going to follow for that, but they're really good at their
所以你可以发送数百万封电子邮件，却只接触到极少数会回复的人，但这正是你想要的，对吧？你只想与那些最有可能给你银行账号的人互动。但呼叫中心诈骗采取了一种新的形式，即给人们施加巨大的时间压力并威胁他们。例如，说你欠国税局（IRS）的钱，除非你现在就付钱，否则警察会来敲你的门。对。他们通常会要求人们做的是去买一张预付现金卡，然后在电话里读出号码。大多数人不会上当，但他们非常擅长施压策略。
pressure tactics so that if you feel like you're in danger, if you feel like you've maybe done something wrong and you're not sure, there's a really strong pressure to just pay up and be done with it. But of course, as soon as you pay up, they're going to be asking you for more money. And I think it's a really interesting case because this has been a really successful industrial-sized business fraud that's been happening. But people should keep in mind that no government agency or formal corporation or any organization that's asking you for money will ever ask you to go buy a cash card and read a number over the phone, ever.
这样如果你觉得有危险，如果你觉得你可能做错了什么而不确定，就会有一种非常强烈的压力让你付钱了事。但当然，一旦你付了钱，他们就会向你要更多的钱。我认为这是一个非常有趣的案例，因为这已经成为一种非常成功的工业规模的商业欺诈。但人们应该记住，没有任何政府机构、正式公司或任何向你要钱的组织会要求你去买一张现金卡并在电话里读出号码，永远不会。
That's always a scam. Nobody's going to ask you to go out and buy cash cards. The other thing is that there's never going to be a case where somebody's going to call and allow you to pay off if the police are on their way to your door. The IRS doesn't send the police to your door based on a phone call and not paying immediately. There's never that much rush. But these call centers have refined their techniques to put you under a huge amount of pressure so that you want to just make them go away.
那总是骗局。没有人会要求你去买现金卡。另一件事是，绝不会有人打电话给你，让你在警察已经在去你家的路上时付清欠款。国税局不会因为一个电话和没有立即付款就派警察到你家。从来没有那么紧急。但这些呼叫中心改进了他们的技术，给你施加巨大的压力，让你只想让他们消失。
And that's been a really effective tactic. So if you get that sort of a call, you can safely hang up because if it's true, they're going to email you, they're going to send you a letter, they're going to ask you to react in some formal way, and you can call the official number, look it up on the lab yourself. call the number they give you, look it up online, and call the official number and see if it's real. It's more often than not, it's not. Dan's story is a great example of, I think, why we sort of fall for this gullibility myth, right? Because we hear a story like this and we think, I would never believe that the IRS is sending the
这是一个非常有效的策略。所以如果你接到那样的电话，你可以放心地挂断，因为如果是真的，他们会给你发电子邮件，会给你寄信，会要求你以某种正式的方式做出反应，你可以拨打官方号码，自己去查。拨打他们给你的号码，在网上查一下，然后拨打官方号码看看是否属实。通常情况下，事实并非如此。丹的故事是一个很好的例子，说明了为什么我们容易陷入这种轻信的神话，对吧？因为我们听到这样的故事，我们认为，我绝不会相信国税局会派警察到我家来收税，还要用苹果iTunes卡之类的东西。到底是什么样的人会相信这些东西？嗯，当然，我是科学家，科学家也被骗过，但他们被骗的方式与此不同。他们被那些懂得如何欺骗科学家的人骗了，这些人编造了看似合理的科研成果，并通过了同行评审等等。所以每个人都可能被骗，但方式对每个人来说都是特定的。那些认为自己老练、优越的人，他们可能会以其他方式被愚弄。也许不是被那种骗局。不幸的是，在诈骗的世界里，总有一些东西是针对我们每个人的。
police to my door to collect my tax bill with, you know, with Apple, you know, with Apple to iTunes cards or, you know, whatever. Who are these people who fall for this stuff? well, of course, I'm a scientist, and scientists have been defrauded, but they've been defrauded in a different way from that. They've been defrauded by people who understood how to defraud scientists by making up plausible research results and getting them past, you know, peer review and so on. So everybody can get conned and scammed, but the way is going to be specific to everybody. And people who think they're sophisticated and superior, they can be tricked in other ways. Maybe not by that con. Like, you know, there's something out there for, you know, something out there for all of us in the world of scams, unfortunately.
我在介绍中提到了人工智能，作为一种可能让人们更容易以各种新方式欺骗和撒谎的技术，例如学生使用ChatGPT写论文，或者人们使用人工智能工具撰写假新闻报道或伪造照片和视频。你认为人工智能会导致各种欺骗和诈骗的大幅增加，甚至出现新的诈骗类型吗？我认为我们在研究这项工作时反复遇到的主题之一是，同样的原则适用于诈骗，正如你所能看到的那样。所以，利用我们的习惯并用我们觉得有吸引力的信息来诱骗我们，这些原则从特洛伊木马开始就一直适用。
I mentioned AI in my introduction as a kind of technology that may be making it easier for people to cheat and lie in all sorts of new ways, such as students using chat GPT to write their papers or people using AI tools to write fake news stories or doctor photos and videos. Do you think AI is going to lead to a big rise in deceptions and scams of all kinds or even new kinds? I think one of the themes that we've run across over and over in researching this work is that the same principles have applied to scams as long back as you can look. So the same sorts of taking advantage of our habits and hooking us with the information we find appealing. That's been true going back to the Trojan horse.
所以在这个意义上没有什么新鲜事。不断有旧骗局的新变体出现。人工智能可能会让一些新的诈骗变体变得更加强大。这是一个我认为特别成问题的案例。现在有一个相当有效的骗局，我有时称之为伤害诈骗或绑架诈骗，有人打电话给父母或祖父母，说你的孩子出了事故。我们需要你立即汇款，这样我们才能让他们在医院接受治疗。
So there's not anything new in that sense. There are new variants of old scams that merge all the time. And AI might allow some new variants of scams to become much more potent. So here's one case where I think it's particularly going to be problematic. There's a scam right now that's been pretty effective that I sometimes call it an injury scam or a kidnapping scam, where somebody calls up a parent or a grandparent and says, your kid's been in an accident. We need you to send money right away so we can get them treatment at this hospital.
那实际上不是医院。同样，这是一种时间压力，利用恐惧，利用你想要立即提供帮助的愿望。通常这种诈骗取决于人们被锁定目标，因为他们知道孩子不在家，并且利用了他们从社交媒体上收集到的关于父母和孩子的一点点信息。但想象一下，如果不是打电话过来，而是由你不知道的其他人打来，如果它是你孩子声音的合成版本，那会有多强大？
It's not actually a hospital. And again, it's a time pressure, preying on fears, praying on, your desire to kind of help right away. Often that sort of scam depends on people being targeted because they know their kid isn't home and they're taking advantage of a little bit of information they've picked up about the parents and the kid on social media. But imagine how powerful that can be if instead of calling up and having it be somebody else that you don't know making that call, if it's a synthesized version of your kid's voice,
这使得它更加可信。所以我认为随着人工智能能力的提高和发展，很多这类事情都有可能被放大。所以，是的，这是一个令人担忧的问题。你可以做一些事情来尝试提前预防。我和家人讨论过的一件事是为我们的家庭设置一个密码，这样如果我们怀疑这是不是真的，你只需要询问密码。如果他们给不出，那就是骗局。这是一个好技巧。而我们现在正把自己的声音放在互联网上供所有人复制。我们在美国心理学会所做的事情之一，
makes it that much more believable. So I think a lot of these sorts of things potentially could be. amplified as AI capabilities improve and develop. So, yeah, that's a concern. And there are things you can do to kind of try and prevent that in advance. One thing I've talked about with my family is having a passcode for our family so that if we ever are in doubt whether this is true, you just ask for the passcode. And if they don't give it to you, it's a scam. That's a good trick. And here we are putting our voices out there on the internet for everyone to copy. One of the things that we do at the American Psychological,
就是...
Association is our IT department sends fake fishing emails to employees, and you're supposed to report them as a training exercise. And of course, there are always people who fall for them. Do these strategies work? I mean, can you really be taught to avoid to be alert to scams? I think you can. I mean, you could start by reading our book. But often, you know, the specifics of a particular scam, those will evolve and change over time, right? So these particular phishing emails that, you know, that the IT department sends are designed to kind of look like the fishing emails that the people who run these business email compromise scams are using these days. They won't perhaps permanently inoculate you against every kind of scam. But I think they're a reasonable form of training.
协会的做法是我们的IT部门会向员工发送虚假的钓鱼邮件，而你应该将它们作为一种培训练习进行举报。当然，总有人会中招。这些策略有效吗？我的意思是，你真的可以通过学习来避免或对诈骗保持警惕吗？我认为可以。我的意思是，你可以从阅读我们的书开始。但通常，你知道，特定诈骗的具体细节会随着时间的推移而演变和改变，对吧？所以，IT部门发送的这些特定的钓鱼邮件，旨在看起来像那些经营商业电子邮件诈骗的人目前所使用的钓鱼邮件。它们或许不能让你永久地对各种诈骗产生免疫，但我认为这是一种合理的培训形式。
And they also help to generate information like 25% of your colleagues, you know, fell for this thing, which can maybe raise awareness more broadly if the scale of the susceptibility. is known. And there have been various research studies that have found surprisingly high percentages of people willing to turn over their passwords and other credentials to these kinds of scams. But they're not a permanent solution. I think to the extent there is a permanent solution, it really involves understanding the patterns of what the scammers are trying to do and what in particular they're trying to target about our own habits and trying to react to that more. there's also a downside to constantly doing that sort of check, which is it makes you distrust emails that seem to be coming from your own administration and your own company. So if you're
它们还有助于生成一些信息，比如25%的同事中招了，如果这种易受骗的规模广为人知，或许能更广泛地提高警惕。已有各种研究表明，相当高比例的人愿意将自己的密码和其他凭据交给这类诈骗者。但它们不是永久的解决方案。我认为，如果说有什么永久的解决方案，那确实涉及到理解诈骗者试图做什么的模式，以及他们特别针对我们自身习惯的哪些方面，并试图对此做出更多反应。不断进行这种检查也有一个缺点，那就是它会让你不信任那些似乎来自你自己的行政部门和你自己公司的邮件。所以如果你
constantly getting faked emails, it makes you kind of like, well, should I believe that this actual administrative email is genuine, or do I just need to assume that they're suspicious of us all the time? So there's some potential backside to that, but training people to recognize the hallmarks of that sort of scam and that sort of fish. is a really useful thing to do. So to wrap up, I want to ask you both, has working on this book and doing this research changed any of your own habits?
不断收到虚假邮件，会让你觉得，嗯，我应该相信这封真正的行政邮件是真实的吗，还是我只需要假设他们一直对我们持怀疑态度？所以这有一些潜在的负面影响，但培训人们识别这类诈骗和钓鱼邮件的特征是一件非常有用的事情。所以最后，我想问你们两位，撰写这本书和进行这项研究是否改变了你们自己的习惯？
Has it made you less trusting or more trusting in life? I do think that having looked at such a wide variety of different kinds of cons and scams throughout history, I learned a lot about ones that I never knew about. And it definitely, I would say, has made me more suspicious, hopefully not in a bad way, but also I think made me a little better at recognizing the patterns that you see among these things, so that when you see some new offer or some new thing, a new story or whatever, you can sort of put it to a framework, you know,
这是否让你在生活中变得不那么信任他人，或者更加信任他人了？我确实认为，在审视了历史上各种各样的骗局和诈骗之后，我学到了很多我以前从未听说过的东西。我可以说，这绝对让我变得更加多疑了，希望不是以一种坏的方式，但我也认为这让我更善于识别这些事物中出现的模式，这样当你看到一些新的提议或新的事物、新的故事或其他什么时，你可以将其归入一个框架，你知道，
where you say, oh, I understand what they're doing in this thing. And that makes it easier to classify, easier to remember, easier to think about how you might avoid it or what you might advise somebody else to do. So I think overall it's quite, it's been quite a positive, even though on occasion it has been dismaying to see what people are doing and what people are falling for. And I think one of the big challenges in this sort of a context is thinking about when you need to be more skeptical, when you need to be more critical, because you can't be a skeptic all the time. That would be a terrible way to go through life, right? You'd be constantly cynical about everybody and everything. But knowing when it actually matters and thinking about
你会说，哦，我明白他们在这件事上在做什么。这使得它更容易分类，更容易记住，更容易思考你可能如何避免它，或者你可能会建议别人怎么做。所以我认为总的来说，这非常积极，尽管偶尔看到人们在做什么以及人们在为什么事上当受骗确实令人沮丧。我认为在这种背景下，最大的挑战之一是思考你什么时候需要更加怀疑，什么时候需要更加批判，因为你不可能一直保持怀疑。那将是一种糟糕的生活方式，对吧？你会不断地对每个人和每件事都愤世嫉俗。但知道什么时候这真的很重要，并思考
when this could be consequential for me, I think that's been something that, looking through all of these sorts of different scams and over history, it gives you a sense of what the patterns are for big risks and helps you kind of think about, okay, do I need to worry about whether the grocery store has given me exactly the price that they promised on the shelf? Well, you know, if a couple of pennies here and there don't matter to me, I can kind of give it a sense of, is this overall close enough? And I don't necessarily want to check everything in detail. So I can kind of let the sort of small scams and small deceptions that probably happen unintentionally all over the place,
什么时候这对我来说可能产生严重后果，我认为这正是通过审视历史上所有这些不同类型的诈骗所带来的收获，它让你对重大风险的模式有了感觉，并帮助你思考，好吧，我需要担心杂货店给我的价格是否与货架上承诺的完全一致吗？嗯，你知道，如果这里那里差几分钱对我来说无关紧要，我可以大致判断一下，这总体上是否足够接近？我不一定非要检查每一个细节。所以我可以放过那些可能在各处无意中发生的小型诈骗和小欺骗，
let those go, not worry about them too much, and really think about it when there's something that could be very consequential. Well, Dr. Simon's Dr. Shabri, I want to thank you both for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Thanks. It's been fun chatting. Yeah, thanks for having us.
不去过多担心它们，而真正关注那些可能产生严重后果的事情。好的，西蒙博士，沙布里博士，我想感谢你们两位今天加入我的节目。这真的很有趣。谢谢。聊天很愉快。是的，谢谢你们邀请我们。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review.
你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取喜爱播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condyenne。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。